right so so a lot of what orwell is
writing about is the stalin regime and
while he sort of lumps all
totalitarianism together right he says
it doesn't matter whether we're talking
about oceania or east asia or eurasia
none of that really matters
what he means by that is that once you
have a totalitarian regime whether it
considers itself nazi or whether it
considers itself communist you're now in
the same boat now there are some
fundamental distinctions between these
ideologies that i think that orwell
elides but his
his ability to critique totalitarianism
is unparalleled which is why 1984 stands
the test of time and there's no question
by the way that many of the incidents in
1984 are attempts to to draw from real
life so for example there's this
character of parsons right who is this
sort of fat bloated idiot who lives in
in winston's apartment building and he's
very excited that his kids are informing
on all the neighbors they're constantly
informing on all the neighbors well this
was a thing in the in the soviet union
under stalin there's a very very famous
situation where a a kid named pavel
marzol was a 13 year old boy
and pawel marezov supposedly informed on
his own father to the gpu which was the
predecessor to the kgb and his father
was received a 10-year prison sentence
and then supposedly marazov's family
beat him to death and so he actually
became a soviet hero there were songs
written about him there are statues
built to this 13 year old kid who
informed on his own father that
obviously is paralleled in 1984.
in oceania your mind is not your own you
have these massive surveillance state
apparatuses that have been built and
that again is paralleled by what the
soviet union did and the goal of the
surveillance in the soviet union was not
just to keep track of people because
they didn't actually have the ability to
process all the material they were
taking in
the idea was that everybody knew that
they were being watched at all times
that inherently changes everybody's
behavior
when you feel like you are on guard all
the time you start to shy away from
exercising your freedom this obviously
has some weaker echoes in the modern
social media era where you feel like if
you say anything then people are going
to come after you and destroy you right
we can feel sort of the faint echoes of
orwell all throughout our society
whether we're talking about the
surveillance state or whether we are
talking about social media mobbings or
whether we're talking about people
informing on each other for mob rule
right so
you know the way that that that
historian robert conquest talked about
the solidarity said to die to lose your
loved ones is bad enough
to be forced to denounce your father or
husband in the hope of saving the rest
of the family and in general to be
compelled in public to express joy at
the whole bloodbath maybe thought worse
still truth almost perished
right so
this was the surveillance state that's
big brother is watching then you get to
the actual slogans war is peace so the
basic idea here is that when you have a
suppressed population you must go to war
you must because you have to direct that
ire somewhere else you see this in
totalitarian states all over the globe
north korea is constantly being
aggressive with south korea not because
they actually hope to win a war with
south korea but because kim jong-un has
to constantly show his population that
the bad guys live on the south side of
the border same thing with china
vis-a-vis for example taiwan and hong
kong same thing for example with iran
which is constantly driving its its
citizens ire at israel or in the
palestinian authority and whenever you
have country russia is a good example of
this right you need territorial ambition
in order to make excuses to your
citizens for why you are a terrible
government and why they have a terrible
living standard and so emmanuel
goldstein in 1984 is the stand-in now
he's actually standing for trotsky in in
1984 and pretty clearly a stand-in for
trotsky because trotsky was used as sort
of the all-purpose whipping boy for the
soviet union during the stalin regime
everybody who was an enemy of stalin was
treated as quote-unquote trotskyite and
then and then targeted but the idea of
course is the perpetual war allows you
to to push all of the ire of your
population abroad and and go after all
those other people now here is where you
get into orwell's failure to understand
actually socialism and communism because
he actually didn't understand socialism
and communism on an economic level
there's a huge portion of the book it's
actually the dullest portion of the book
where he gets a hold of goldstein's
pamphlet
and he reads the pamphlet and the
pamphlet is just straight trotsky it is
pretty much an open paraphrase of the
revolution betrayed by trotsky and and
that the revolution betrayed basically
says communism is good stalin is bad and
you hear the same thing here right the
idea in in the goldstein pamphlet is
that the reason that the state has to
constantly go to war is because if it
were not for the state going to war
they couldn't get rid of all of their
excess wealth and getting rid of the
excess wealth sinking it to the bottom
of the sea as orwell puts it keeps the
people in misery and keeping the people
in misery is the goal because if they're
in misery then it prevents them from
being able to rise up that's not true
okay communism keeps people in misery
because it inherently destroys all the
wealth
soviet union did not need to go to war
with surrounding countries in order to
destroy its surplus wealth it had no
surplus wealth it was an impoverished
country masquerading as a first world
nation
and then you get to the second slogan
freedom is slavery
so again the idea here is that to be
free is to actually be a slave to be
fully free means that you are a slave to
your own impulses and only when you are
liberated from individualism and you are
subsumed under the rubric of the state
can you experience true freedom now in
order to do that you have to give up
your own mind and this brings us to
ignorance's strength which is the third
slogan and the most important slogan of
the state ignorance is strength that
when you give up your own mind to the
state
then you find strength because now
you are united with everybody else
you've been merged into the great
collective and the key to this and this
is i think orwell's best point in the
whole book i think his best point is
this the key to this is the pushing of
subjectivism the pushing of the idea
that you can create reality within your
own mind and this is what is constantly
being pushed by o'brien o'brien of
course is the emissary of the of the
state who is trying to brainwash winston
right and uh and
smith talks about this right he says
what was terrifying was not that they
would kill you for thinking otherwise
and that two plus two equals four but
that they might be right for after all
how do we know that two plus two make
four or that the force of gravity works
or that the past is unchangeable if both
the past and the external world exist
only in the mind and if the mind itself
is controllable
what then
so the idea is that you destroy
all objective truth and once you've
destroyed all objective truth all that
is left is the subjective and then when
you apply pressure to the subjective
mind what you do is you destroy freedom
because again you can think yourself
into anything is the premise here now
there is an external world right there
are facts there are realities out there
this is why it is very important for us
to cling to the facts of life we do not
cling to the facts of life and if we
believe that all reality is made up
inside of our tiny pea brains then it's
very easy for people to exert control
to use the power of of
the culture to use the power of the
government to compel you to think things
because after all reality is created in
your brain it is not an external thing
out there for you to discover
this is orwell's great point the most
dangerous philosophical thing you can
get into is radical subjectivism and
that is where we are as a society and he
keeps hammering that home right he
hammers that home over and over and over
in 1984.
right
it's described in the book as quote
every record has been destroyed or
falsified every book has been rewritten
every picture has been repainted every
statute and street and building has been
renamed every date has been altered and
that process is continuing day by day
minute by minute history has stopped
nothing exists except an endless present
in which the party is always right so
what is the hope here right it's pretty
hopeless books pretty grim book right by
the end winston who has fought back
against the state essentially by taking
a lover and again i think that that is a
a
misstatement of how you fight back
against
totalitarianism it really is not about
emotional subjectivism it's about
vital institutions that you build on top
of your emotional feeling for other
people so institutions like marriage
institutions like church you need those
to fight the state otherwise they can be
wiped away winston falls in love with
julia they have a relationship the state
destroys it anyway
so he says that he has hope in the
proles and trotsky says this too he has
hope for the lower classes because the
lower classes still grip tight to their
personal relationships it really isn't
about that it's about the fact that
elites in society have a nasty tendency
to tear down the institutions that are
necessary in order to allow life to
continue normally
and the proles grip those institutions
tightly
it turns out that william f buckley once
suggested that he'd rather be governed
by the first 200 names in the boston
phone book than the than the faculty at
harvard the reason for that is because
the faculty at harvard think themselves
into the belief that they can get rid of
all the institutions
whereas normal people they live within
those institutions they live marriage
they live family they live school they
live church
they live local community
those are the things that are absolutely
necessary right that really is the hope
there's one other point that i think
orwell is wrong about there's a lot he's
right about there's one other point that
i think orwell is wrong about in the
book and that is this he suggests
through o'brien right who's the emissary
of the state that the reason that this
is being done is for pure power
it's almost a nihilistic desire for
power it is not about some sort of
higher cause i don't think that's right
i don't think that communists actually
believe in just pure power rule
i think it's actually
forgive the phrase a slur against stalin
i don't think that stalin was just about
promoting his own power he actually was
utopian
as the philosopher
philosopher karl popper suggested
utopianism is the danger it is not just
that you have nefarious movie villains
who twirl their mustache and talk about
we're so powerful we're gonna use our
power to abuse everyone else there are
some people like that for sure
beria who was one of the heads of the
kgb for a while the head of the gru he
was like that but most people who do the
most damage in life are people who are
actual
ideological utopians who believe that
they can cure the problems of humanity
if you give them enough power and that
we see every single day in american
politics and unfortunately all over the
world